[Music]  i know this is the first time some of  you will see  combat i know you're scared  let me be clear with all of you  i'm scared too  welcome to france gentlemen i lead the  local resistance cell  something big is happening inside  gestapo headquarters  and we don't know what it is we're gonna  have to improvise here  members of the resistance are perhaps  the bravest  people fighting in this war  but you really should stop there is no  future in it sorry to interrupt  [Music]  lieutenant  [Music]  it'll be a wild ride but we'll get you  there  jet fighters brace yourselves  like i said boom  there are things as people  i'm willing to sacrifice myself for  [Music]  somehow this motley crew has been tasked  with saving civilization  god help us all  [Music]  you